you know it amazing how much in in a
situation that doesn't life just have
storms I mean the storms not just real
they're metaphorical too I mean there's
a it's a metaphor
we all got storms don't we one time or
another sometimes you can predict them
sometimes you can't you can't see it
coming always you don't know what's
happening but in an amazing how just a
thousand dollars that's not that much
but how many options and how much peace
that can give you just a thousand bucks
I mean and so there's a reason to do the
stuff we teach here it's not just a Dave
Ramsey thing it's not just a biblical
way of handling finance thing it's not
just good for you to be grown up it's
not all that it it's a better way to
live your life I mean what if you had a
fully funded emergency fund and you were
facing all these things and you had
20,000 bucks set aside and no payments
at all it's a different thing to face
life when it comes at you the storms of
life but I mean really it is a good
metaphor when they come at you it's a
different thing to face that with a
little bit of Apollo money or it could
even be the guy that stopped in the
lobby he was here Thursday he and his
wife they were in Nashville said were
you doing in Nashville he said well we
live in North Carolina and we thought
it's a good time to come to Nashville
and throw a party so what do you mean he
goes what we're millionaires we've been
doing the stuff you teach for years and
we're completely out of debt we got a
net worth over a million dollars and we
thought this is good time to go
Nashville does it change your
perspective when every decision you make
doesn't create yet another crisis I
remember just something as simple as a
car breaking down every time the car
would break down at our house we had a
hillbilly drama crisis I mean we would
throw I would throw stuff at the car get
mad have a fit stupid car
I hate this car I hate every car that's
got this color on it the stupid
are on the side of the road again I wish
someday I could get you give a wine
clink whining is a little-known form of
prayer I'd go into like super Hawaiian
mode ever done that yeah you have you
know you have what's interesting was
once I got an emergency fund in place I
remember the first time we had about ten
thousand dollars in the bank and the
transmission went on the car actually we
went out on the van because I pulled the
boat with the van with the shifter in
the over drop position so I fried the
transmission because I was stupid but
that's how it went out smoke filled the
car and my children were yelling that
they were all gonna die and this is what
happens if you put the drive shifter in
the wrong place and pull the boat anyway
so yeah I got to put a transmission in
the van because the weirdest feeling
we're driving away from the place after
we put the transmission that we paid I
know 1700 bucks or whatever it was for
the transformation 100 years ago and we
were having away because we just went in
and picked up the van I wrote a check
and there was no hillbilly drama it was
like weird it's like this is just an
emergency becomes an inconvenience when
you have some money so the purpose of
this show is not to say rich people
don't have any troubles the purpose of
this show is to say get some money get
you some money it's called an emergency
fund is one of your first steps get you
some money get yourself out of debt quit
buying crap that you can afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't really like stop it get you
some money because the storms are coming
you're gonna do something stupid and fry
your transmission there's gonna be a
hurricane that something's gonna happen
but a crisis is not a hillbilly drama
it's an inconvenience when your
millionaire you come to Nashville have a
party it's gone Kylian convenient to be
over here right now there's a hurricane
so I'm gonna go over there and I'm just
gonna get on a plane and fly over there
and rip me a car and get me a really
nice hotel and go to some nice
restaurants and when we get back home
we'll see what's left work it out
it changes everything it changes
everything when someone in your family
is ill and you can go be with them or
you can even help them through that
process it changes everything when the
storms of life hit I don't want you to
be rich because you're greedy and I'm
not teaching you to be greedy I'm not
greedy that's not the point
but money is an interesting thing
my friend pastor Craig Groeschel says
why is it wealth is the only blessing
from God that we apologize for well I
don't apologize for it I want you to
work hard come by it honest save some of
it be it grown-up and then when a crisis
comes it'll be an inconvenience